naim hussein had attended the funerals
of two muslim men murdered in the last
two weeks in albuquerque new mexico on
friday
that night police say he was ambushed
his family says his friends found him
shot to death in his car the friends
that saw the body they said it was a
head shot so i don't know
if it was a single shot or if it was
multiple shots now police are
investigating if the three murders are
linked to the murder of another muslim
man muhammad ahmadi last november and
are asking the public to help find the
driver of this car which might be
connected to the killings we are also
increasing our air support
now that we have information about a
vehicle of interest that kind of support
is going to be crucial but in
albuquerque the muslim community has
been shaken by the murders you walk out
of your house
not knowing if you're going to be
followed
and targeted
that is what is on the mind of every
person
leaving their home in albuquerque that
happens to be a muslim
there is no sense of safety while police
are not saying if the men are being
targeted because of their faith hate
crimes against muslims are increasing in
a dozen of the largest jurisdictions
including california new york city
chicago
anti-muslim hate crimes rose
from 84 to 122 or 45 increase and these
data are usually
predictive of trends
four men from afghanistan and pakistan
who emigrated to the u.s gunned down in
their chosen hometown
the latest nahim hussein received his
citizenship just last month and was
planning on bringing his wife in
pakistan to live here the dream was to
buy their own home patty calhane al
jazeera